these days the news is pretty insane is
it not it's crazy every single day we
are constantly being bombarded with
jaw-dropping and ridiculous stories but
we found a way to put the day's news in
perspective with the help of our good
friend mr. Deon Cole that's right
Dion breaks it down let's check it out
okay let's done a big story of worship
that the Trump administration said was
headed for North Korea actually wasn't
headed for North Korea but today Sean
Spicer said that's not lying because one
day the worship will go to North Korea
does that like me saying I'm dating
Rihanna because some day I might be
dating Rihanna yeah it's kind of like
that yeah
the tell Rihanna I'll pick up at 8:00
until Sean spices to shut the hello all
right okay here's another story Rachel
Dolezal that's remember her she's the
woman who was born to two white parents
but says she identifies as black just
released a memoir about life as a racial
minority does she plug her book on The
Today Show I know she didn't will she
ever guest on the reel yes she was well
if she's black get the sisters book and
tell all them to shut the hell up
hey here's a new story Starbucks has
come out with a drink called a unicorn
Frappuccino that's right but some health
experts say you should avoid it because
it has too much fat and too much sugar
the sugar make you feel good yeah it
does yeah just fat make you feel good
yes yes it does are we all gonna die
anyway in World War 3 because Donald
Trump don't know what he doing probably
then go ahead and drink your giant
rainbow milkshake and wash it down with
a bacon double cheeseburger those help
alright and finally earlier today Fox
News fired host Bill O'Reilly because of
his alleged history of verbal and sexual
abuse is Bill O'Reilly a tall Irish dude
who has a long-running show on cable
television
named after himself it has millions and
millions of fans but secretly was a bad
dude yes been calling it I think you
should shut up
[Applause]
all right thank you
secretly a bad dude
you